foreign
business and economic news from the
heart of the city now the government has
tweaked the terms of its windfall tax on
oil and gas production in the North Sea
the move threatened follows evidence of
a collapse in investment in the North
Sea which supports some 215 000 highly
paid jobs will the government introduced
a tax rate of 75 percent on North Sea
oil and gas production when Energy
prices soared last year following
Russia's invasion of Ukraine the 75 levy
on North Sea oil and gas production
but it will revert to its previous level
of 40 if oil and gas prices fall below
their long-term average for a period of
six months the floor has been set at
71.40 for a barrel of crude oil and 54
Pence a thumb for gas the energy profits
Levy has raised around 2.8 billion
pounds to date that's according to the
government which expects it to raise
almost 26 billion pounds by March 2028.
we're going to be speaking very shortly
to the offshare offshore energy
production uh business Lobby do stay
tuned for that now any day now Vodafone
is expected to announce it's merging its
UK operations with three the UK
telecom's arm of Hong kong-based CK
Hutchison it would be the biggest
shake-up of the mobile to Nephilim
Market in this country for many years
and it comes off to complaints from
Vodafone and others that the market is
so crowded it's stifling Innovation and
investment but a deal is likely to come
under heavy scrutiny from the
competition and Mark its Authority we're
joining us Palo Pescatore he's the
founder of the tech media and telecoms
uh consultancy PP foresight Paulo good
to see you this morning I mean they've
been talking to each other for a year
these guys what's taken something so
long
good morning again good morning to
everyone thank you for having me on the
show yes they've been talking for a
while there's no specific deadline or
timings on the deal but you know reports
seem to suggest that you know we could
be days or even weeks away and who knows
until May not even happen so let's see
what happens over the next few days
I mean do you think the CMA is likely to
block this I mean they did after all uh
blocker takeover by O2 uh by a vote two
by three uh in 2016.
it's a very good question so of course
you know under the current regulatory
environment and as you said the
president has already been set in the
the failed free O2 deal you know it
really hinges on the balance of whether
both entities can really prove the
merits of the deal is really in the
interest of UK PLC and you know whether
you know the real test will really come
whether they can prove you know there is
a failing firm uh between either one or
between of uh between the two of them
you know long term because they're
having to invest huge sums of money and
you know is it uh sustainable to have
two sub-scale mobile operators when you
have you know ee that's been merged into
uh BT and obviously O2 into Virgin Media
so I think that's where it all hinges on
and then you know naturally there has to
be some concessions that need to be made
around the Spectrum network sharing and
if all parties can work together to
provide some form of resolution and
provide Solutions rather than create
another problem then certainly it would
stand a better chance of trying to get
over the line
you've made the point there that these
two are fairly subscale compared with
the other operators in the market I mean
Vodafone argues that uh this is
inhibiting investment does it have a
point
well to a certain degree uh yes all
mobile operators are investing heavily
in upgrading their networks and of
course you know we're now moving towards
uh Standalone uh 5G but naturally there
aren't that many subscribers to actually
acquire and even though both both
companies have outperformed the market
over the last year in terms of net ads
continuing to invest at the rate that
they are doing is unsustainable and even
the off-com acknowledges the return on
Capital employed is less for for these
two particular players and of course you
want to increase competition rather than
you know reduce competition naturally
when you are reducing the number of
players in the market of course you're
reducing choice but um that could be of
the benefit to UK PLC from an economic
productivity perspective it was better
to have three stronger players than
having you know two and then of course
you know from the opposite side of the
spectrum they're virtually integrated
because even if still does get over the
line it still doesn't address the the
issue that you know the combined entity
lacks having that convergence compared
to the top two players you mentioned 5G
there would the would this merger have
any implications for 5G rollout
well to date we haven't seen a huge
impact but you know the argument I guess
both entities were put forward that as a
combined entity you know they could
actually dedicate more resources to the
rollout of Standalone 5G and then
eventually millimeter away and then
obviously Next Generation technology
which will obviously be 60 and Beyond
all right Paulo we've got to leave it
there good to talk to you this morning
thank you
well back now to our top story which is
that the government has tweaked the
terms of its windfall tax on oil and gas
production in the North Sea the
government introduced a tax rate at 75
percent on North Sea oil and gas
production when Energy prices sold last
year this morning it's announced it will
drop the levy if price is full joining
me now is David Whitehouse he's chief
executive of offshore energies UK David
welcome to you
um is this going to be enough to get
investment going again in the north
series of damage already being done
if I could maybe just to provide some uh
some context really on today's
announcement so so in the UK 75 of the
energy we use comes from oil and gas and
we produce domestically about half of
that I think it's very clear for our
energy security for the 200 000 jobs
that the sector employees and actually
also for the future energy transition
it's really important that we continue
to see investment in the in the oil gas
sector there is no doubt that the energy
profits Levy has caused problems I think
from our membership 90 of the oil and
gas operators have said that they've
been cutting back our on investment and
as a sector we have been calling on the
government to do something to to help us
I think I think what we hear today is we
will get a price trigger and that's a
mechanism that we have been calling upon
and we welcome that so so a price
tracker effectively means that when the
wind pool is no longer there windfall
tax goes away and we think that's fair
that's fair for operators we think
that's fair for consumers we need to
work the detail though uh the whole
intent of today's announcement is to
unlock investment and we will work with
our members with the oil and gas
operators and actually also with the
banks and the lenders just to confirm
that this truly will unlock the
investment that the sector and to be
honest the country needs
what I struggle to understand David
maybe you can help me with this is that
when the windfall tax was announced the
government sought to Sugar the Pill by
announcing a 91 percent uh tax relief on
investment in the North Sea why hasn't
that worked
I think the tax rate to some degree is
is of a system but what we're really
looking for actually is a stable
long-term lower tax rate that actually
means we've got stable investment uh
going forward and in some way shape or
form we don't want to see those that
those higher higher tax levels driving
those those um higher incentives I think
are unhelpful what we want is stable
long-term uh regime for the oil and gas
sector that means people can plan people
can can deliver projects and actually
that's good for the oil and gas sector
that's good for the UK and ultimately
that's good for consumers
now you mentioned there a lot of the
questions over the detail there I mean
the floor has been set at 71.40 per
barrel of crude and 54 Pence per thermal
gas what do you make of where the
floor's been set
I think it's something we're going to
we'll have discussions with uh with with
treasury I think I think we see the gas
prices is lower than them as an industry
that we were looking for and I think
again for me this is this is part of the
detail and the discussions we need to
now have with with Treasury and then
actually with with our investors and
with lenders just to ensure that the uh
the mechanism that's been proposed today
will unlock the investment that the UK
needs are are they already seeing job
losses in the North Sea following the
imposition of the windfall tax
I think unfortunately we are we are we
you know we you hear it actually it's
not just uh not just up here in Aberdeen
but up and down the country you are
seeing jobs uh being eroded so a number
of
um uh I think a number of the assets
from the North Sea are already
disappearing overseas I think not only
is the tax causing an issue but I think
also what is going on in America where
the IRA is also I think luring the the
supply chain away so yes we are seeing
that and it's really important that we
change that
um a successful energy transition a
successful oil and gas sector in the UK
is really important we we represent over
400 excellent supply companies and
they're absolutely the the supply chain
companies that uh that if we can have
the investment in oil and gas they will
be there to invest in our future in
Renewables and actually driving the the
energy transition here in the UK so we
are seeing those job losses really
important that we turn that around now
the labor party is already critical of
the existing uh Levy it says that uh it
doesn't go far enough just put it into
context for me if you would how the UK
tax is oil and gas production compared
with some of our peer economies
so so what you see is the you compare
the 75 that we're currently paying and
that's three times more than any other
company here in the in the UK and you'll
find that there are other there are
other tax regimes in the world which uh
which is similar levels but
fundamentally the UK is one of the
highest tax regimes now and I think
actually more importantly to some degree
it's also the fact that it's become
unstable what companies look for is
stability they want stability they want
consistency they want political support
that's what we really need to deliver
for the long-term future not just of the
oil and gas sector but for the energy
sector across the entire UK now David
while I've got you uh I mentioned the
labor party just now they've had an
long-standing commitment to borrow 28
billion pounds to uh fund green
investment it looks this morning as
though they may be rowing back on that
your reaction please
I think there's a labor party uh
policies to for them to dictate
themselves what I would say though is
actually for the energy transition I
think is really important to the UK it's
a great opportunity the North Sea offers
some fantastic opportunities we've
powered the country for 50 years and
actually we're going to power the
country for the next 50 years through
oil and gas but actually also through
offshore Wind Through hydrogen and uh
and carbon storage so one of the things
about today's announcement is it is a
step it's a first step in a longer path
of ensuring actually we do attract that
investment and we do drive that longer
term ambition in the energy transition
delivering Net Zero by 2050 for the for
the UK all right David good to leave you
there appreciate you joining me today
thank you
no thank you very much
uh Rishi sunak and the U.S President Joe
Biden have agreed a new partnership to
bolster Economic Security the agreement
includes a narrow trade pact covering
critical minerals needed for electric
car batteries close to defense industry
Corporation easing trade barriers and a
new data protection deal but the Prime
Minister has blamed the pandemic and the
war in Ukraine for the UK government's
failure to strike a full-blown trade
deal with the U.S
today we have agreed the Atlantic
declaration
a new economic partnership for a new age
of a kind that has never been agreed
before
yes a partnership that protects our
citizens
but more than that
a test case for the kind of reimagined
alliances President Biden has spoken so
eloquently about
the British Chambers of Commerce has
upgraded its forecast for UK GDP this
year but warned that the economy is
flatlining an expected growth rate of
0.3 percent for the whole of 2023 Rising
slightly to 0.6 in 2024 and one percent
in 2025 for joining me as Vicky price
she's an independent member of the
British chamber of commerce's New
Economic advisory Council Vicky welcome
to you before we get into the forecast
I'd just like your reaction to uh what
Rishi sunak was saying there has he come
back with anything substantive do you
think from the US
well I think he has uh we knew anyway
that there wasn't going to be a trade
deal it was very clear uh that that idea
has been abandoned by the U.S certainly
and the hope of achieving one uh really
wasn't on the cards uh as uh the the
actual visit was taking place
um but at least what I think we've got
back is some commitment to ensure that
the whole move in the states to uh
subsidize quite significantly its own
industry to encourage more green growth
and so on is not going to happen by
excluding entirely you know vast chunks
of the UK manufacturing sectors such as
the car industry and of course the
Europeans are trying to so the rest of
Europe is trying to do the same thing as
well with discussions on how to get
integrated into that vast subsidy
element because otherwise what you're
going to end up looking at in the future
is real trade barriers and competitive
Advantage going to the US and the
detriment of us all so I think that's
quite good so there are some sexual
issues
generally that I think are going to look
better in the future and of course just
declaring this close relationship is is
good news because it had drifted away
and I think there could be a lot that we
could build on it now we mustn't get too
excited about it but it's certainly
better than not having that particular
Alliance if you like that has been
declared between the two countries
well let's talk about your forecasts
what's uh informed these upgrades
well what we've seen of course in the UK
is that Grove
year and also slightly better in the
previous quarter they've been
anticipated of 2022 the last one
um and we've seen also consumer spending
being
um slightly stronger than had been
anticipated confidence is a bit better
we've seen the latest data which still
suggests that the consumer is quite
confident despite the squeeze in
household disposable incomes and we've
also seen investment staying slightly
higher than anticipated as well so the
resilience of the UK economy obviously
needs to be taken into account when
you're looking at what may happen in the
six months ahead but what we know is
that the growth that we're seeing right
now is is Tiny so when we're forecasting
growth of 0.3 percent that could go
either way and you've seen what's
happened in Europe where they have just
for the Eurozone at any rate they've
just re-calculated their figures for the
first quarter which was suggesting a
slight increase before to now a drop so
they are in technical recession in the
Eurozone not in the EU as a whole so
things could go either way and I think
it's going to be very very important to
look at business sentiments ahead and
any uncertainty in government policy
could tip the balance really back into
recession and we certainly are looking
at forecasts that are suggesting there
may be there will be the quarter of no
growth or best possibly small decline in
one of the quarters that follow this
once so we're not really in safe
territory yet and the forecasts are not
really about anyone
um anticipating anything big to happen
in 2024 and 2025 and that's the real
worry how do we get back to fast growth
and fast productivity I'm very
interested though that you say uh things
could go either way do you see the risks
to your forecast being more to the
upside or the downside
the worry on the downside has a lot to
do with what happens with consumer
spending because of course we've had the
mortgage increases I've taken place just
recently and they are already affecting
people's ability to finance their debts
and also remortgage uh for their
households um that they've got right now
which is becoming considerably more
expensive so there is an issue for the
of affordability if people then react by
spending Less in other things given that
of course right now we still have very
high food price inflation then that
could tip things the other way because
as I said earlier consumer spending has
been a very important part of keeping
things going so the services sector
continues to grow on the other hand you
have manufacturing which is in uh
recession has been seeing declines in
monthly outputs since last August so
that our chance of economy that are not
doing very well construction has done
well because of civil engineering
activity and commercial building but of
course the house building side is also
so the high interest rates and further
increases in interest rates that we may
indeed see and whereas anticipating
there will be another quarter point
arise
could well affect consumer sentiment
quite significantly if that happens
given that services are such a large
part of the economy then indeed we could
see a Slowdown happening from here on
all right Vicky got to leave you there
appreciate you joining me today it's
good to catch up with you thank you
it's another business news stories for
you now and the U.S grains giant Bunga
is in talks to create what would be be
one of the world's biggest agricultural
trading companies it's seeking to merge
with vitera which is owned by glencore
the ftse 100 commodity trading and
Mining Company the combined business
would be worth around 25 billion US
Dollars and it will be one of the
world's biggest traders of wheat corn
and soybeans the deal is likely to be
scrutinized closely by Regulators coming
at a time when the war in Ukraine has
raised many questions about the security
of Supply in Global Food Markets
the uk-based Payment Solutions provide a
network International has agreed to a
takeover valing it at 2.2 billion pounds
the buyer is Brookfield the Canadian
asset management company whose existing
UK assets include the holiday Resort
operator Center parks and a 50 stake in
the property group Canary Wharf Well
network was founded in 1994 and provides
services and solutions that allow more
than 150 000 Merchants mainly in the
Middle East and Africa to accept digital
payments from customers
and Amigo Holdings the failed subprime
lender said today it had received an
approach from one of its shareholders
that could save it from folding the
company which began an orderly wind down
of its operations in March said it had
been approached by Michael Fleming a
financier and shareholder to request an
exclusivity agreement in relation to the
business Amigo warned that there was a
very low likelihood of a successful
conclusion to any discussions and said
that even if a deal could be reached
there was not expected to be any value
for shareholders
now the recent launch of chat GPT by
open AI has sparked an upsurge in
interest in generative artificial
intelligence but you could be forgiven
for thinking that all the running in the
technology is being made by the likes of
Microsoft and Google but they are not
the only ones and there's growing
interest in Silicon Valley at what Adobe
the software company behind Photoshop is
doing in the field it's been giving away
tools on a new website called Firefly
which includes new photo editing tools
and a service that can create art and
images from a simple text command
similar to open ai's Dali app for
joining me now is Anil chakravarthy he's
president of the digital experience
business at Adobe Anil welcome to you
are you trying to build generative AI
applications from scratch or are you
trying to more to incorporate them into
your existing products
hi thanks for having me on pleasure to
be on we are actually using generative
AI in a variety of ways we are building
it from scratch for our Imaging products
so you have you mentioned Photoshop it's
Photoshop and the integration of
Photoshop with firefly anybody who's
using Photoshop can just enter a prompt
and say hey put a boat for me here or I
want a picture of a lighthouse and they
can actually edit their images and make
their images more beautiful with the use
of generative AI that is technology
built from scratch we also are
integrating with generative AI for
across our other applications including
the large language models like you
mentioned with openai so we're doing
both
how rapidly do you see AI becoming
Incorporated by companies into their
workflow processes
yeah I think the AI is going to be
transformative uh in its use across all
kinds of applications I'd like to give
you an example we are building what we
call a copilot for marketers you know
this show here that we are here in
London uh it's called our Adobe Summit
it's been attended by a number of
marketers around Europe and what they're
all trying to do is how to do a better
personalized marketing deliver better
customer experiences to all of their
customers whether it's through their
digital channels like their web and
mobile apps or for people who come into
their stores or through other venues and
channels the way they do that is through
the use of AI to really better
understand who which customer segments
to serve what they care about how to put
better experiences in front of them and
do it at the right time through the
right channels all of that's being made
possible through AI now you're rolling
out Firefly at the moment to your
Enterprise customers how much are they
going to have to pay for it
the Firefly is right now in beta with
the Photoshop any customer who already
has Photoshop has access to Firefly
through Photoshop so that's already
included in their Photoshop in the
subscriptions they acquire from us for
the Creative Cloud we also have a new
product called Adobe Express that is uh
that's available to all customers we
just announced Express for Enterprise
customers so as a part of the express
products now these are these prices for
Enterprise customers depends on the
number of seats or users that they have
as well as the number of images they
intend to generate based on that there
will be pricing and packaging based on
that obviously there's a big debate
going on right now about potential
regulation of of AI but as a developer
how do you stop your customers from
abusing the service
we have a number of things that we're
doing we have something called the
content authenticity initiative the
content authenticity initiative was
actually started initially to help
counter misinformation deep fakes and
things like that and that has come in
obviously at a perfect time for AI we
allow every customer who uses Firefly
every image that's generated through a
firefly will have content credentials
showing how it was generated so we have
content credentials that show whether
something was created by a human being
whether it was created by Ai and then as
it gets changed we track what changes
happen to it so that's really important
to make sure that you know the origin of
any kinds of images that you generate
any kind of other content that you have
on the open uh internet you know where
it's come from who generated it what
changed and these kinds of content
credentials this kind of content
authenticity is a critical part of
making sure that it is accurate
information
how are you building safeguards into
Firefly to ensure that people use it
don't for example infringe the copyright
of copyright owners and characters
that's exactly right so the way Firefly
has actually been trained it has been
built to be commercially safe so what we
have done is made sure that every image
that it was trained on all the data sets
that went into the AI models were
licensed images so we've made sure that
everything there was nothing was scraped
off the internet everything was licensed
and we make sure that all the inputs are
licensed there in addition we make
Firefly models available for every
Enterprise customer for their own data
set so for instance if you are a brand
and you have the trademarks for your
particular brand you have an instance of
firefly where you can import those
images you train that on the on the
Firefly data set and the generated
images are only for your exclusive use
they are not made available to other
people who don't have access to your
images so that's how we make sure that
intellectual property copyrights are
protected as as the use of firefly
becomes widespread I know it's been
fascinating talking to you this morning
thanks very much and leave for joining
me thank you
still to come here on in King live we're
gonna have a look at how the markets are
going into the weekend stay with us
foreign
[Music]
I think the rise is mainly in the
younger age group so the under 24s and
what we're seeing is I know we've been
seeing this for a number of years the
the a change in sexual behavior so the
the hookup culture there's more casual
sex especially in this this age group as
well
um in addition there has been some
budget cuts
um and that has meant that the
educational side of things has
diminished as well so we're not
teaching the younger younger adults
about sex and safe sex in the way we
used to teach them so that's of course a
bit of a perfect storm in the fact that
there's a change in behaviors especially
after people come out of the pandemic
and being locked down and there's been
less education about things that a lot
of the the the people who are young in
the 80s took for granted about condom
use and safe sex and a lot of young
adults find it quite difficult to talk
to the parents about their current
sexual behavior and and
um and some of the activities and and a
massive part of what the that Pro those
programs used to do was give out free
condoms and and teach about consent and
teach about the wider sexual behavior we
look after
any child in terms of how they're
dealing in the social environment and
what's going on at home
um and we're open to have the
conversation so if anyone who is under
the age of 18 but having sex we record
it competence which if they can consent
we talk through safe sex and um
contraception they are usually quite
easy to treat gonry is a strange one
because gonorrhea there is a very
resistant strain of Gonorrhea at the
moment
um which needs a slightly longer course
of antibiotics
um and so that's why testing's so
important knowing that you have these
syphilis has has been at the highest
level since 1948.
I'm not just
exactly and that's because people are
the behaviors are changing and people
don't know the signs of it's almost like
we almost eradicated it and people
aren't picking up the early signs of it
because it's not painful and it can
disappear for long periods of time
[Music]
well Wall Street solid finish last night
was followed by gains for equities in
most of the asia-pacific region
overnight the Nikkei in Tokyo Rose to
finish close to the 33-year Hyatt hit on
Tuesday to complete its ninth
consecutive Weekly game well in Europe
stocks have been mixed this morning
here's the current picture you can see
the Dax in Germany are slightly
underwater they're the other main three
continental European indices just about
in positive territory talking points
this morning include daso system the
software maker is off two and a half
percent in Paris following a trading
update well here in London the ftse 100
is pretty flatish there it's uh three
points off right now consumer stocks
Weighing on the index to an extent the
leading Blue Chip Faller in percentage
terms is quite a big one there to
mention here this morning crota the
Specialty Chemicals group is down some
14 right now following a profits warning
among leading ftse gainers right now is
AstraZeneca that follows news at the U.S
Healthcare regulator has backed the use
of an antibody az's been developing with
sanofia France to tackle respiratory
infections in children outside the ftse
100 the North Sea oil and gas producer
Harbor energy has rallied nearly three
percent after the government's floor on
the North Sea windfall tax rival ethica
energy is ahead by two and a half
percent for similar reasons as
AstraZeneca uh on the foreign exchange
markets uh I think we can show you
what's uh going on there here we go a
sterling uh offer an eighth of one
percent right now against the US dollar
more or less unchanged against the Euro
meanwhile The single currency is also
off by around a fifth of one percent
against the dollar as for the oil price
well that's set to four for the second
week running that's largely on demand
concerns so as you can see right now it
is ahead Carla Brent crew will currently
set you back
76.31 cents a barrel that is up a little
under half a one percent on the session
joining me today back by popular demand
is Bill dilling Chief investment officer
at raverson Investment Management Bill
good to see you this morning let's start
with Japan I mean um it really is on an
absolute tear the Nicky well it is and I
it's very interesting you know
foreigners uh sort of were very excited
a few years ago when prime minister RB
sort of started his reform program and
then uh they lost interest and it was it
was a real sort of round trip I think
foreigners bought you know the same they
bought 250 billion I was having a huge
amount of money and then they sold it
and recently they've come back and I
think that's quite interesting and I we
think there's a lot very good Japanese
companies I mean globally competitive
leaders in certain industry Industries
and so I I think Japan is definitely
back but there's potentially an awfully
long way to go because domestic
investors in Japan are still incredibly
bruised by what happened 30 odd years
ago and I think to really get that
momentum in the market it's going to
require more than just the foreigners
I've seen one piece suggesting that a
lot of this interest in Japan from
foreign investors is because people no
longer want to have their money in China
yet if they want to retain exposure to a
major Asian economy Japan's really the
obvious choice I think that is a part of
it we've got we have an Asiana Southeast
Asian Equity strategy and we're seeing
some real interests from American
institutional investors and a lot of
them are actually talking to us about
the fact that they're Keen to think
about Asia X China
so with all the political uh issues
between the United States and China a
lot of U.S institutional investors some
of them will be in public sector some of
them might be in Academia some of them
might be in areas where they they're
nervous about doing things that the the
government may not wish them to do
there's definitely I think a move of
capital out away from China from U.S
investors that should be the benefit
hopefully of our Southeast Asian
strategy but also I agree with you it
could well benefit Japan yeah it's
fascinating now closer to home of course
we learned this week that the Eurozone
is is in a technical recession is that
something you're particularly worried
about I mean it's a very very shallow
downturn well yes I mean I I think yes
but it's it's technically yes I think
that what we continue to be mostly
worried about is what's happening in the
United States for the U.S economy
particularly the U.S consumer has
continued to be remarkably resilient and
that's kept the U.S economy uh growing
more than a lot of people had expected
ourselves included we still think
there's an over 50 probability of a
recession in the States but I would have
embarrassingly said that six months ago
and it hasn't happened yet and it's that
consumer
perseverance that that matters I think
and I I think what we'll hope what I
suspect will happen is that the US
consumer will slow if that happens then
I think that's a challenge further
challenge both here in the UK also in
the Eurozone quite often Europe you know
on this side of the Atlantic our
economic cycle is tends to be pretty
coincident with the US so if we're
already quite sluggish here you were
talking earlier about slight upgrade in
expectations in the UK but again we're
talking you know tenths of a tenths of a
percent if the US economy does slow then
I think with an already weak economy in
Europe then that could get more
problematic later in the year all right
always good to see you Bill thanks for
joining me today
still to come here on Ian King live
keeping the gas flowing I'll be joined
by the chief executive of national gas
to talk about maintaining supplies stay
with us
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back well with temperatures this
weekend set to hit their highest levels
so far this year you may not be thinking
too deeply just now about your energy
bill this winter but with wholesale gas
prices still higher than they were
before the war in Ukraine and tight
margins between supply and demand for
gas across Europe there is still plenty
of reason to be cautious we're helping
keep gas flowing smoothly between
Britain and Europe is one of the
priorities for national gas which
operates the gas transmission Network
manages 7 million gas meters and
incorporates the gas system operator the
chief executive of national gas is John
Butterworth and he's with me now John
welcome to you how concerned should
people be about security of Supply this
winter
yeah good morning yeah yeah I I mean um
you know we've got this covered um our
key role um for the UK is to make sure
that we have resilience and security of
Supply so the 23 million domestic
customers the half a million industrial
customers and the power generators on
average in 2022 we did about 38 of power
we're making absolutely sure now
throughout the summer that our system is
resilient and we've got everything in
place so it can we can get through next
winter
suggest what are you doing to build
resilience
yeah so lots of things are going on
right across the Enterprise you know we
take gas from the beach uh we move it
through enormous pipelines through a
series of gas turbines and dispatch it
to the cities where we blend it as it
comes on Shore and filter if it needs
and filter it so um you know what we're
doing is making sure that all of our
assets are in Tip-Top condition that all
the key parts that are needed are on
each individual site with double shifts
and resilience and we're working with
government who've been extremely
supportive and off gem to make sure that
everything is as best as it can be as we
head into winter obviously we don't have
the storage facilities in the UK that
some of our Continental European peers
do why isn't more being done to address
that
yeah so you know with government you
know we're looking at that but you know
we're in a great place in the UK because
we've got the jewel in the crown of
Europe which is the North Sea so we've
got gas supplies that can come in from
the North Sea we've got gas supplies
coming in from the Irish sea and we've
got our enormous LNG terminals that can
bring Cargo in as well as well as
storage on the mainland so you know
we're in a good place for winter now
you're also investing very heavily in
hydrogen you're a great believer in that
what are the chances of it ever fully
replacing natural gas is that likely do
you think
yeah absolutely I mean if you think
about it you know there's three times as
much energy this morning going through
the gas system and the whole of the
Electric System and On a Winter's day
it's five times greater uh than goes
through the Electric System and tens of
thousands of businesses from fish and
chip shops to um you know cement works
and and lots of homes you know they
can't Electrify so the only option is to
move and lean into hydrogen from natural
gas and we have an enormous plan and a
big test site on the Scottish border
where we are currently working through
slowly blending at low levels of
hydrogen in the gas stream up to a
hundred percent by 2050. you know when
the wind doesn't blowing the sun doesn't
shine you know and I'm from Manchester
and the sun does not shine that often
it's really important that the balancing
mechanism for the huge amount of energy
this country uses is hydrogen so it's
important that we get that up and
running and introduce it into the gas
Network as fast as possible
now until fairly recently you were part
of course of National Grid you've just
been demerged from there the grid still
retains a 40 stake in you how quickly
would you expect that to be sold down
yes so we would expect that to be sold
down and that's in train at the minute
by the end of the year
okay now one of your new owners of
course is Macquarie the uh Australian
Investment Bank previously an owner of
Thames water uh during which time they
didn't exactly cover themselves in glory
how can you be sure they're not going to
do to you what they did to Thames
well you know I can only talk from my
experience we were the the deal took
place in February of this year and you
know they they have invested and and
they've backed the farm on hydrogen and
uh they know they are there with masses
of investment to put forward already to
help us lean into hydrogen for the
future so you know I'm really pleased
and delighted with Macquarie uh and the
other investors because they want to get
involved in transforming Us in the UK to
hydrogen and that's really important
because most properties in the UK are
not suitable for a heat pump 84 of all
the houses that around are around today
are the same houses that will be around
in 2050 so it gives us the opportunity
to give people choice and businesses
choice so people can choose whether they
want a heat pump hydrogen ready boiler
etc etc so that everybody out there has
got the choice and the affordability to
make a good decision for themselves so
we're delighted with Macquarie because
they're leaning into hydrogen and
putting the money where the mouth is
okay John we have to leave it there good
to talk to you this morning and
hopefully you do get a bit of sunshine
up in Oldham this weekend thank you
thank you very much
now stock exchanges globally have had to
invest heavily in technology in recent
years to support activities such as high
frequency trading and see off possible
cyber security threats at the same time
though earnings from their traditional
activities have been squeezed by
Regulators obliging them to diversify
into activities such as data provision
and clearing Services well the biggest
Market operator in the EU is euronext
which runs the stock exchanges of Paris
Amsterdam Milan Brussels Dublin Lisbon
and Oslo I've been speaking to its chief
executive Stefan bujna and began by
asking him about his priorities for the
next 12 months
we need to make sure that you're on X
which is much larger at the time of the
IPO and which is a group which is
already very Diversified away from Cache
Equity trading which represents now only
20 of the top line of the group is is
much more Diversified in non-equity
businesses in non-volume related
businesses you've obviously carried out
a number of Acquisitions over recent
years there's still more to come on
sensing from what you've said absolutely
absolutely uh and I would make a
difference between the consolidation of
exchanges where you have to basically be
ready when those assets are
actionable when when the owners decide
to to to sell I mean that's what we've
done in Norway where we waited for the
assets to become for sale what would you
have done in in Italy where we waited
until lse was put in a situation where
for antitrust reasons they had to sell
the Boss 8 in a group so the other
significant Assets in Europe that are
possibly going to to to evolve in their
shoulder base
we'll have to to be ready if and when
for the diversification ambition it's a
bit different because the universe is
much wider be in fund distribution in
bus trade in Forex in Commodities in
data there is always asset rotations
among private Equity owners among
industrial groups that decide to carve
out certain assets so
here we monitor situations we enter into
dialogues in most cases we we submit
non-binding offers and we withdraw
sometimes we we we continue so
like in any uh very systematic m a
process but I'm confident that with
valuations changing with the impact of
interest rates increase and and the new
momentum in the private Equity world I'm
confident that there will be a much more
significant trend of a asset rotation
hence how many opportunities for us now
you've maintained a very significant
presence here in London post-brexit
how has the business changed since
brexit we have
far more people in our London office now
than we had in in 2018.
and um and that's because we have made
several Acquisitions and some of the
Acquisitions we've made at teams in
London that we have gathered but it's
also because we have significantly
increased all commercial uh effort in in
London the reality is that
some decision makers have decided to
relocate operations within the EU others
have decided to stay in London so we
have a
developed or commercial efforts in
accordance to this nutrition clearly if
you want to bank
European clients if you want to operate
on European venues you need to be based
within the EU that that there is no
magic about that yeah London used to be
the largest financial center of the
European Union it's now the largest
financial center of the United Kingdom
with global Ambitions and with a very
strong leading position on some asset
classes in particular
four eggs or or or post trade for
example
but when it comes to financing the real
economy when it comes to listing to to
equity trading to anything which is even
even to corporate bonds anything that is
closer to to to the needs of of the
issuers or to managing the savings of of
the of the retails then clearly you need
to be close to operations and therefore
to be regulated in the EU so this this
polarization started for euronex the
what is interesting is that I started in
the proxy referendum took place in June
16 and in parallel to the brexit process
the long process between June 16 and and
February 2021 we we have built a company
that had at the beginning a 400 million
Top Line which now has a 1.5 billion Top
Line which has at the beginning a 1.4
billion market cap which has now a
market cap between seven and eight
billion so in parallel to brexit we have
built a platform in Europe consolidating
local exchanges building a leadership
enlisting building a leadership on on
cash Equity trading so those two
processes have developed in parallel
there's obviously a big debate going on
in London right now about the
attractiveness of of the UK as a
destination to list
are you seeing any signs of of that in
some of the territories where you have
exchanges yes we we see a massive shift
on the one hand if you want to list in
Europe now and you prefer to list within
the European Union and if you want to
list in Europe you have an option now to
list in the market which is much bigger
than the London Market which is the unex
market we have a single liquidity pool a
single order book a single technology
platform that trades today between 10
and 12 billion dollars per day in
average a volumes which is approximately
twice the volumes traded on on on in
London so as I said earlier when it
comes to equity to issuers to the
financing of the real economy clearly
there has been a shift from London which
was an offshore platform to the core of
Europe because euronex is now able to
address those needs
that's uh Stefan booze now from euronext
talking to me earlier a bit of breaking
news to bring you the University of
Manchester has said this morning it has
been the victim of a Cyber attack its
systems have been accessed by an
unauthorized party and some data
accessed it says it's working around the
clock to resolve this in the meantime
the National Crime agency the
information commissioner's office and
the national cyber security Center have
all been informed still to come here on
inking live we're going to have a look
at what's in the business Pages this
morning don't go away
[Music]
I think the rise is mainly in the
younger age group so the under 24s and
what we're seeing is I know we've been
seeing this for a number of years the
the change in sexual behavior so the the
hookup culture there's more casual sex
especially in this this age group as
well
um in addition there has been some
budget cuts
um and that has meant the the
educational side of things has
diminished as well so we're not
teaching the younger young adults about
sex and safe sex in the way we used to
teach them so that's of course a bit of
a perfect storm in the fact that there's
a change in behaviors especially after
people have come out of the pandemic and
being locked down and there's been less
education about things that a lot of the
the the people who are young in the 80s
took for granted about condom use and
and safe sex and a lot of young adults
find it quite difficult to talk to the
parents about their current sexual
behavior and and
um and some of the activities and and a
massive part of what the that Pro those
programs used to do was give out free
condoms and and teach about consent and
teach about the wider sexual behaviors
we look after
any child in terms of how they're
dealing in the social environment and
what's going on at home
um and we're open to have a conversation
so if anyone who is under the age of 18
but having sex we we call it Gillette
competence which if they can consent we
talk through safe sex and um
contraception they are usually quite
easy to treat gonry is a strange one
because gonorrhea there is a very
resistant strain of Gonorrhea at the
moment
um which needs a slightly longer course
for antibiotics
um and so that's why testing's so
important knowing that you have these
syphilis has has been at the highest
level since 1948.
exactly and that's because people are
the behaviors are changing and people
don't know the signs of it's almost like
we almost eradicated it and people
aren't picking up the early signs of it
because it's not painful and it can
disappear for long periods of time
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
[Music]
thank you
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
[Music]
try and have a look at this morning's
business pages and the financial time
splashes its print edition with news at
the hedge fund manager OD asset
management is facing a widening
investigation by the UK's Financial
conduct Authority and the loss of
crucial banking relationships it comes
after an ft investigation in which 13
women made allegations of sexual assault
and harassment against the firm's
founder Chris bin Odie that story
followed up more or less everywhere
right now the ft is currently leading
its Digital Editions meanwhile with
Donald Trump's claim that he's been
indicted on federal charges in
connection with classified documents
found at his Mar-A-Lago residence in
Florida the times leads its business
pages with news we brought you this time
yesterday that the Eurozone today
technical recession it also reports that
Paris is claiming to have overtaken
Frankfurt in the battle to win finance
jobs that have been created in
Continental Europe as a result of brexit
meanwhile The Daily Telegraph leads its
business pages with news at HSBC has
pulled all of its current mortgage
offers after being overwhelmed by Russia
applications from customers looking to
lock in deals before interest rates rise
again it also reports on its business
front page that Marx and Spencer has won
a dispute with The Confectionary company
Swizzles after accusing it of copying
its Percy Pig Suites well with me this
morning is Neil Collins the financial
markets commentator and evening standard
columnist Neil good to see you this
morning love to get your reaction to
what the government's announced this
morning on the energy windfall tax
well on the face of it it's good news
because it is a sort of tax cut but
really it does display the sort of
complete shambles at the heart of how
taxation is uh is made in this country
uh and it's in the mission that the last
time they put the taxes up was a serious
error and we've seen the way that the
industry has reacted
by threatening to cut jobs and stopping
developments in the North Sea because
it's just not worth doing you know if
all the the profits are going to be
taxed away what's the point and it's all
very well him saying now that if the oil
if the oil price Falls far enough then
we'll cut the tax rate but
um what's to say that he won't change
his mind if the oil price goes up again
or
um
in invent some other system to uh to to
skim still more off with the state you
know if I was a uh running an oil
company an oil exploration company I
would say well thanks for this but
really it's stability that we want
stability and fair taxation that we want
and at the moment we really haven't got
either and there are other places to
look for oil other than the north city
uh which will
produce no benefit at all to the UK so
um I just I despair really you know they
just don't seem to have any coherent
plan of what they should be doing but
then it's worth
remembering that uh Cenac when he was
Chancellor ruled out a windfall tax on
the oil companies and then when he
became prime minister
um his new Chancellor changed the rules
to impose one so you know this is a
long-term industry and 10 years is the
sort of planning uh Horizon and you
can't plan sensibly if the rules are
being changed every few months and I I
despair the the government's inability
to see this
just because they were pushed by popular
demand into into imposing the so-called
windfall tax on the oil companies last
year uh it's you know you you react in
that sort of knee-jerk way this is the
sort of consequence that you get and I
don't think we should be surprised
yes population of populism never makes
for good policies does it Neil we've got
to leave it there I'm afraid good to see
you this morning thank you
thank you
that's it from me there's much more on
the Sky News Mobile app and on the
website with reporting video content and
Analysis from our business team among
the pieces up there right now look from
me at who the potential Runners and
Riders are uh to buy The Daily Telegraph
Sunday Telegraph and spectator magazine
do have a look at that if you can but
after this short break it's Sam
Washington with the latest reaction to
the government's move on the windfall
tax this morning I'm back on Monday at
10 o'clock hope very much to see you
then thanks for joining me today have a
great weekend cheerio
foreign
[Music]